celle du petit é l'église est
que vers le sol natal mon corps soit
ramenée dans un sleeping du paris
méditerranée terminus en gare de sète
monga bonne famille est là ce n'est pas
tout neuf
vulgairement parlant il est plein comme
la fin
que quelqu'un m'entende
il risque de se faire tard et je ne peux
dire à ces braves gens ou cboe donc un
peu la sauce jones en quelques sortes
il est mort le poète aurait dit son
compagnon de scène gilbert bécaud mort à
60 ans tout juste georges brassens avait
fêté son anniversaire il ya huit jours
moi aussi là où il le voulait tout près
de 7 à saint génis dû faire face au
cimetière marin de paul valéry qui
chantait tout à leur terminus en gare de
sète
il venait de subir une intervention
chirurgicale pendant l'été il souffrait
plus longtemps de calculs rénaux et à
force de faire des pieds mené à la mort
celle qu'il appelait parfois la
faucheuse ou la camargue s'est vengé
puis tout le monde est riche et nous
chez vous chez ses copains qui seront là
tout à l'heure à bobino où il devait
préparer sa rentrée au début de l'année
prochaine on il a tout bête
à 20 ans à 40 60 on a perdu un oncle il
il est mort ce matin huit jours après
avoir fêté ses 60 ans georges brassens
était né le 22 octobre 1921 à sept fils
de maçon il fait ses études à
montpellier puis il monte à paris
ils pratiquent plusieurs métiers et il
est découvert par pâte à choux on est
alors en 1952 sa carrière d'auteur et
d'interprète commence il chante dans les
grands cabarets parisiens la france
découvre peu à peu cet ours mal léché au
coeur tendre
les 135 titres de son répertoire sont
sur toutes les lèvres
son oeuvre avait été couronnée entre
autres par le grand prix du disque de
l'académie charles cros en 64 puis par
le grand prix de l'académie française en
depuis plusieurs années georges brassens
souffrait atrocement de coliques
néphrétiques qu'ils ont à plusieurs
reprises conduit sur une table
d'opération
et c'est peut-être pour cela qu'ils
disent est familièrement avec la mort
dans ses chansons chaque fois que je
meure fidèlement chantaient-ils ils
suivent mon enterrement
c'était un homme simple demeurer simple
ne vivons pas à la recherche forcenée de
la gloire il n'avait joué qu'une fois
dans un seul film porte des lilas et il
détestait le cinéma seule comptait la
compagnie de ses copains l'écrivain rené
fallet son contrebassiste pierre nicolas
les copains d'abord dans le jeu du
saucisson et du beaujolais
c'était un homme d'un autre âge à
troubadours un vrai égaré dans notre
siècle georges brassens vient de mourir
on pourrait reprendre pour lui cette
phrase qu'il avait eu à propos de la
récente mort de jacques brel quand on
aime les gens
il meurt bien sûr c'est à dire qu'il
s'absente un petit peu jamais personne
de ce que j'ai aimé n'est mort alors les
copains d'abord ils sont là en partie
sur ce studio louis nucéra qu'il
connaissait depuis 27 ans puis d'un d'un
quart de siècle où la vie rencontre est
qu'à l'occasion
j'étais journaliste à nice j'étais allée
l'interviewer comme on dit et c'était à
l'époque où j'étais plein de certitudes
et je trouve qu'il a eue
beaucoup de patience avec moi et on
ouvre quelques jours une fois il m'a dit
tu sais la révolution dans le fond c'est
d'essayer de s'améliorer soi même en
espérant que les autres fassent la même
démarche
j'ai eu au début j'avais trouvé cette
phrase un peu comme un lieu commun et
puis je crois que c'est une phase
essentielle banale qui avait germé en
moins et si tout le monde de respecter
on ne s'aviserait pas de diriger autrui
quand il est déjà difficile difficile de
se diriger soi même dans la vie alors
son côté nounours qui apparaît comme ça
quand on le connaissait vraiment son
côté est ce qu'il est mais les gens ce
qu'ils n'étaient pas plus misanthrope
pas du tout mais en europe c'était
l'homme le plus chaleureux et une sens
de la fidélité un sens de la discrétion
son côté nounours si on veut c'est parce
que il faisait partie d'un monde où
beaucoup de gens ou souvent la sottise
s'est mise à penser aux beaucoup de gens
résolvent des problèmes sans même en
connaître les données et lui qui quand
il signé des articles dans le libertaire
qualité d'un anarchiste de la tradition
individualiste il est signé pépin
cadavres ou joe la cédille eh bien ils
avaient qu'à conserver ce goût d'une
certaine violence en lui c'est entre
entre amis qu'il a proféré cette
violence sur des choses qui
l'exaspéraient mais quand il était
interviewé à la radio à la télévision
il savait que ce métier de chanteur que
ce métier du spectacle un site beaucoup
de jeunes gens à imiter la personne qui
chante et à personne est une star qui
est une vedette
bien que ce mot avec lui est un peu mal
venue et alors il hésité à se prononcer
sur les grands thèmes sur les grands les
grands sujets du monde quand on lui
posait une question sur la guerre aux
sur je ne sais quelles questions qui
n'étaient pas bien au courant et cela
c'est pour ça qu'il paraissait si vous
voulez un peu ours parce qu'il nous
voulait répondre que sur des choses
qu'il pouvait espérer de connaître comme
toutes les personnes qui savent beaucoup
il savait qu'il ne savait rien piano qui
s'était aussi à les copains
georges brassens où vous l'aviez connu
il ya vingt ans à peu près j'écoute
vraiment bien en 62 je fais ma première
tournée avec lui 1,62 et puis deux puis
vous l'avez pas lâcher c'est plutôt
c'est lui qui m'a pas lâché quand il
rentrait comme premier chanteur vivant
d'anthologie des dépôts est chez ces
guerres je crois ou vous pensiez
vraiment que c'était un poète s'arrêtant
impôts être pour les jeunes générations
plus tard bien sûr sans vous savez moi
je peux pas vous dire grand chose je
suis venu parce qu'il fallait venir mais
même avec georges en définitive on a eu
beaucoup de silence oui j'allais chez
lui puis on disait quelques petites
choses et puis opérons alors le silence
continue et on respecte votre émotion
pierre louki voilà longtemps qu'il
n'avait pas chanté sur scène on le
disait tout à l'heure il préparait donc
ça rentrait pour le début 82 dans sons
musicaux le favori il n'en sortait pas
souvent c'était bobino et bien en ce
moment là bas c'est l'un de ses fils
spirituels qui passe maxime le forestier
et puis sur place chez les machines ni
chez les artistes
un grand rideau de chagrin daniel
leconte oui il ya beaucoup de monde ici
dans les files d'attentes qui ont été
stupéfaits en apprenant la nouvelle
et puis vous savez dans la salle maxime
le forestier va passer dans un quart
d'heure les maxime le forestier était un
ami très proche de georges brassens
puisque il doit fait passer une première
fois avec l'huile dans son récital en
1972 ici à côté de nous nous avons
madame de vitry qui était direct
madame de vitry qui était directrice de
de cette salle et qui a connu brassens
la première fois quand il est passé même
de vitry ont dit que brassens avait
beaucoup le trac cette fois ci il avait
toujours le tac mais il l'avait pas il
est très pudique
mais quand il retrouvera seul c'était
drôle parce qu'il traînait sa guitare et
en plus ils s'insurgent ils respectaient
le week-end ce que je fais là j'en ai
marre joue pas ici et puis traînée puis
il mettait le pied sur son chevalet puis
voilà il chantait j'étais saint georges
et nous avons aussi une dame qui devait
assister au spectacle de maxime le
forestier elle était très surprise
d'apprendre tout à l'heure la nouvelle
je vais vous demander ma dame qu'est ce
que représentait pour vous brassens pour
vous et pour votre famille pour ma
famille pour moi même y représentait un
grand poète et sa mort bouleverse
énormément pour moi c'était un être en
dehors des affaires du show-business
c'était un pur pour vous brassens un
poète un vrai poète comme vision comme
ronsard comme qui chantait la nature qui
chantait tout ce qu'il y avait de ça
je le regrette beaucoup alors oui sur
place et puis de nous faire peut-être
entendre à 23 heures la réaction de
maxime le forestier après son tour de
chant tout à fait je voudrais vous dire
en même temps que maxime le forestier va
consacrer la troisième chanson de son
récital ce soir et vous la verrez à 23h
dans le journal oui à sète sa ville
natale grosse émotion également depuis
deux heures depuis que l'on a appris la
nouvelle je passe également sur les très
nombreuses réactions qui sans place sur
nos bureaux
je retiens celle du prema république
georges brassens avait supporté avait su
porter haut
l'alliance de la poésie et de la musique
et son oeuvre est déjà inscrite dans le
patrimoine culturel français a dit donc
le chef de l'état en écrivant à la
famille de georges brassens
alors nous l'aimions beaucoup antenne 2
comme partout d'ailleurs il était venu
animer notre soirée sur la paix et quand
jacques brel on le disait tout à l'heure
et mort en 78 et le premier à qui nous
avons appris la nouvelle et le regardait
à ce moment-là commis par les biens de
son ami c'est parce qu'il faut le faire
aussi ne faut pas le faire en réalité
lancée rien si on n'avait pas insisté
pour me voir je crois que je me serais
dit filet et de notre côté comme ya
tellement de gens qui aiment jacques il
est difficile de pas positif c'est
vraiment tout ça titre est difficile
c'est un ami c'est un membre dans notre
famille qui est mort et c'est difficile
à en reparler
vous savez moi j'aime bien parler de la
mort pour rigoler mais sérieusement je
sais pas le faire que je pense pas qu'il
soit avec ce qu'il a fait avec ce qu'il
a écrit avec ses qualités d'homme et ses
qualités d'écrivain d'auteur il n'est
pas mort comme s'il était vivant je
pense qu'il il est plus vivant
maintenant que jamais paul fort disait
il faut nous aimer sur terre il faut
nous aimer vivant ne croît pas aussi me
dire il faut nous aimer avant initiera
vous l'avez entendu évidemment tout un
flot d'anecdotes qu'hirson qui sont
ressortis qui montra sa générosité par
exemple la générosité par exemple jour
un ami avait besoin
d'argent et ils lui avaient prêté cet
argent à cet ami et s'est mis à une
table sans doute pour écrire une
reconnaissance de dettes et georges l'a
dit mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
mais j'écris une reconnaissance de
dettes lit mais tu crois que j'ai pas
confiance en toi alors l'ami lui a dit
je vais peut-être confiance en moi mais
si je mets et qu'est ce qui te
remboursera et georges dit mais si tu
meurs tu ne crois pas que c'est l'argent
que je regretterai ou alors un jour je
me trouvais à bobino ayant monsieur
dépenaillé qui est venu lui demander de
l'argent il lui a dit très loyalement je
sors de prison
si vous pouviez me prêter quelque chose
je crois qu'il avait quarante mille
francs sur lui ne fait je parle l'ancien
fin il lui a donné 20 mille francs la
moitié et puis bon cela arrivait souvent
parce que les gens célèbres comme lui
sont souvent tapé et bien deux ans après
ce monsieur est ce monsieur lui avait
dit et vous savez si vous me prêter cet
argent
peut-être ça va m'aider à repartir dans
la vie et deux ans après ce monsieur est
revenu et il avait eu un beau costume
il n'était pas rentré d'une façon
subreptice dans les coulisses il a dit
voilà je suis le monsieur sortie de
prison que vous avez aidé et voilà
maintenant je vais me rendre votre
argent et voilà georges brassens quoi
vous n'êtes pas arrêter d'en parler
parce que parce que c'est vraiment un
type d'exception voient les ministères
il y avait un autre grand moment
télévision c'est humain un moment
d'amour tout court lorsque dans le grand
échiquier jacques chancel
il est parlé de sa mère et vous allez
voir c'est tout brassens il ya de
l'amour et puis et puis a beaucoup
d'humour
ma mère qu'est pays qui était d'origine
italienne napolitaine pas comme lui
voilà
elle avait horreur évidemment été très
petit bond à l'avs et horreur de mes
chansons en gros mois elle ne nous
écoutait pas d'ailleurs et dans chaque
lettre elle me disait 16 ans d'écrire
des choses pareilles écrit les
parapluies écrit la chasse aux papillons
écrit l'auvergnat est voulu que ne
voulait me voir recommencer toujours là
la chasse aux papillons le parapluie
puis à l'eau qui s'il faut vous
souveniez d'une chose de georges
brassens qu'est-ce qui vous aura appris
qu est-ce qui vous ont allégué comme
testament dans la chanson presque tous
je veux dire que c'est du jour où ceux
des petites chansonnettes pour m'amuser
c'est du jour où j'ai entendu les
premiers 10 de brassens que j'ai
vraiment envie d'écrire
autrement outre choses dans la vie d'un
comportement humain je sais pas je sais
pas où vous demanderiez faire quelques
jours mais là je sais pas pour les idées
très nombreux les amis de le pierre
brassens à réagir comme comme pierre
louki de georges brassens pardon et nous
allons évidemment continuer à les
interroger et demain soir une grande
forêt sur antenne 2 à 20h30 consacré
évidemment à georges brassens puis à la
fin de ce journal de chansons parce que
c'est un petit peu manqué à cette
émission spéciale
nous avons improvisé en moins de deux
heures
la nouvelle nous est parvenue à 18
heures de chansons donc tout à fait à la
fin de ce journal
deuxième type de l'actualité ce soir le
procès ma tension procès exceptionnel à
tous égards la cour d'assises de l'isère
s'est en effet transporter ce matin dans
la banlieue grenobloise pour tenter de
retrouver les restes d'olga moïse cenco
suivent en cela les navigations de
l'accusé qui hier avait craqué et avoué
trois crimes donc le président les jurés
les avocats et l'accusé ont passé une
bonne partie de la journée à l'extérieur
mais les recherches n'ont donné aucun
résultat
la cour a alors décidé d'arrêter des
fouilles et de reprendre les audiences
tenues et c'est rarissime en plein air
jusqu'à de me mettre la justice
reprendra alors son cours ordinaire
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
paul de faire patrick simpson jones et
freddy auxerre il y avait un plan
dessiné hier soir par matencio le voici
reconstitue
c'est par là que la cour d'assises a
commencé ce matin à 10 heures
voici le président robert fabre l'avocat
général puis les avocats puis les jurés
à côté du fourgon et autour une foule
avec une quantité de journalistes
matencio visiblement ne s'y retrouver
pas à ce moment là seul matencio savez
si cette longue journée ne serait qu'une
farce ou au contraire la recherche de la
preuve et de sa bonne volonté et aussi
de sa culpabilité
le petit chemin l'ancienne route
d'uriage est situé à la base d'un
plateaux escarpés sur lequel matencio a
surpris olga moins cinq co et son fiancé
matencio comme prisonnier de la cour
d'assises a dans un premier temps
indiqué à un endroit bien précis puis un
autre situé à quelques kilomètres du
premier tout le monde s'est déplacé pour
venir finalement au premier endroit
matencio affirmé que le corps d'olga se
trouvait près de ce poste d'eau matencio
la a répété qu'il était le meurtrier
mais paradoxalement il dit qu'il n'a pas
lui même enterré la jeune femme une
contradiction qui jette le doute sur
l'ensemble de ses déclarations
à midi les pompiers ont commencé à
creuser à cet endroit qui apparaît
bizarrement proche de la route pourrait
dissimuler un cabas ce petit chemin et
chaque jour
le rendez vous d'amour heures à 13
heures les jurés sont allés déjeuner les
pompiers eux ont continué à creuser
à 15 heures on a recommencé les jurés
ont regardé ce grand trou vide matencio
aux siens alors le président a réuni la
cour d'assises dans un
deux gendarmes dont celui ci et
l'audience a repris tout le monde
aligné comme pour une excursion là dans
ce cas ce matin dessus a dit oui oui
j'ai tué un soldat et je ne sais plus et
son corps ce n'est pas moi qui les rend
se veut ni qu'il ait bien des brigades
rouges ainsi matencio est revenu à sa
première version
l'homme à ce moment là est apparue et
s'entendent puis suicidaire muet tout
cela n'a servi à rien alors la cour
d'assises est reparti à grenoble les
départs reprendront demain les jurés
aujourd'hui on était bien étonnés de
voir comment pouvait parfois fonctionner
la justice
autre procès retentissant celui de roger
knobelspiess à rouen la cour d'assises
de seine maritime l'a finalement
condamné à cinq ans de réclusion
criminelle en assortissant d'ailleurs
cette décision de modalités qui devrait
lui permettre de kipé très rapidement la
prison s'ils pouvoir exécutif le
souhaitent
l'avocat général vous rappelle avait
demandé trois ans de prison
la compagne de knopp bis jacqueline de
prost a été condamnée elle à deux ans de
prison et elle sortira libre du tribunal
on peut donc considérer que ce verdict
de la cour d'assises de rouen est un
verdict de clémence
claude sérillon ce verdict peu banal le
jury de la cour d'assises de rouen a
émis le voeu que les cinq années de
réclusion criminelle contre roger
knobelspiess soit théoriquement décompté
à partir du 4 mars 1977 date de son
arrestation
et comme devant s'achever le 3 mars 1982
les jurés de rouen ont souhaité
également qu'exceptionnellement l'octroi
d'une mesure de grâce présidentielle
soit faite à roger knobelspiess si la
requête en révision de son premier
procès où il fut manifestement
injustement condamné venait à être
refusée
c'est clair pour les jurés de rouen les
arguments du procureur vayrac et de son
défenseur maître leclerc étaient les
bons on ne pouvait dissocier les faits
commis est reproché du passé de roger
knobelspiess de l'injustice qui lui fut
fait
j'ajoute banc en finir avec cette
affaire de justice qu une nouvelle
opération de police a été déclenchée la
nuit dernière à marseille à la suite de
l'assassinât du juge michel 300
personnes ont été contrôlées mais les
résultats ne semblent pas significatif
pour l'instant enfin un aumônier de
prison un pasteur a été tué ce matin à
son domicile par un ancien détenu de la
prison de fleury mérogis qui l'abrité
chez lui depuis sa sortie de cellule un
document maintenant en provenance d'iran
fait qu'il est très difficile d'y
tourner des images très peu de journées
s'obtiennent des visas pour se rendre
sur place
aussi le film que vous allez maintenant
découvrir et qui nous est parvenu par
des voies détournées il amiens ce un
mois pour cela rend-il toute sa valeur
il s'agit d'un affrontement en plein dé
rentrer partisans et adversaires de
l'ayatollah khomeini gérard sauvage l'un
des quartiers de téhéran une colonne de
fumée des hommes armés sans uniforme
sans doute des moudjahidine du peuple
des opposants de gauche il traîne sur le
sol pour le mettre à l'abri de l'un des
leurs blessé ou tué
alors que retentit des rafales d'armes
de m
par l'intensité des tirs le déploiement
de ces combattants il est nettement
perceptible qu'il s'agit d'un accrochage
sérieux d'un véritable combat 2
selon les lois en vigueur ces hommes
pris les armes à la main sont
immédiatement et sans procès passible du
peloton d'exécution
ces images sont la preuve et sans doute
pour la première fois des cotons de
certitude qu'il existe maintenant à
téhéran une véritable opposition armée
et organisées contre le régime de la
gâteau la comédie et que l'insécurité
qui règnent à téhéran prend par moments
des allures de guerre civile
les travaux de l'assemblée suite de la
discussion budgétaire avec aujourd'hui
un affrontement sans violence mais ferme
entre laurent fabius et les députés
communistes et dernier estimé que la
force de concessions bien on finissait
par vider le projet d'impôt sur la
fortune de tout son sens
non a répondu laurent fabius l'essentiel
a été fait désormais il existe un impôt
sur la fortune et le ministre du budget
de rappeler au groupe remy nice quatre
membres du pc était au gouvernement
et comme il d'ailleurs sont pas les
seuls à se plaindre certains socialistes
son grenier mais en silence
et puis syndicat force ouvrière des
impôts estiment que cet impôt est réduit
à l'étape au tchad alors que
rapporte-t-il pourquoi est il si
difficile de l'imposer en france
christian marion l'idée d'une taxation
sur la fortune des français date du
début du siècle en 1914 joseph caillaux
proposa le premier projet sans succès en
1924 le cartel des gauches leur visage
il fut vite abandonnée suite est le fuit
abondante de capitaux en 1945 il prend
le nom d' impôt de solidarité face à
l'énormité de la tâche
il est mis aux oubliettes en 1949 la
fiscalité française s'efforcera sous la
vème république de cerner la fortune des
français françois-xavier ortoli en 1968
mettent en place les droits de
successions et des donations en 1973 une
loi aménage la très ancienne taxe
foncière et en juillet 1976 le président
valéry giscard d'estaing décide un impôt
sur les plus values en 1978 les députés
socialistes tenteront de déposer à
l'assemblée une proposition de loi
instituant un impôt sur la fortune
sans succès c'est en octobre
1981 que l'assemblée nationale va
adopter à l'impôt sur la fortune en
excluant les objets d'art mais surtout
pour la première fois elle permet la
mise en place d'un contrôle sur la
fortune de 1 % des français on croit que
l on va dans dans tous les pays
européens vers une meilleure
connaissance des revenus et une
meilleure connaissance des mêmes des
capitaux mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut procéder avec une certaine
lenteur vous pouvez pas du jour au
lendemain
transformer une structure fiscale le
droit fiscal est un droit qui suppose
une certaine continuité
une certaine limitation une certaine
tolérance tolérance aussi bien la part
de ceux qui appliquent l'impôt que
acceptation que consentement de la part
de ce qu'ils subissent
ça suppose toujours cette idée de
consensus qui je crois doit s'affirmer
devrait s'affirmer dans toute la mesure
du possible alors sa vie et députés de
la majorité qui s'était également
beaucoup pas l'armé de la sphère paribas
ont peut-être noté avec humour que
paribas suisse veut faire un souterrain
anti hold up au propre et non pas au
figuré afin de parer au danger éventuel
d'ahold port de transfert des valeurs et
je pense que si jacques delors avait pu
faire ça plus tôt après avoir eu moins
de problèmes avec philippe sassier
maintenant les conséquences pratiques de
l'accord de l'opep hier à genève sur un
alignement des prix mais aussi sur un
gel jusqu'à la fin 81 gel du prix de
pétrole pendant 14 mois offre un répit à
l'économie mondiale un répit sur lequel
le plan économique du gouvernement
aurait rencontré beaucoup de difficultés
en clair cheikh tamani donne passez moi
l'expression un véritable coup de main à
jacques delors l'an prochain la france
veut réussir un doublé c'est à dire
courir plus vite sans accident cardiaque
connaître un taux de croissance plus
élevés 3,3 pour cent avec un taux
d'inflation - fort 10%
rien de cela n'est possible si les prix
du pétrole continuent de flamber
ils ont triplé depuis 1978 actuellement
la conjoncture française connaît une
réelle embellie
exportations augmentent la consommation
intérieure progresse la production
industrielle repart un nuage noir des
investissements industriels sont
toujours au point mort mais la
perspective de stabilité des prix du
pétrole pourrait les inciter à reparti
malgré l'augmentation du coût de nos
achats pétroliers qui va se traduire par
une augmentation du prix de l'essence à
la peuplent gel du prix du pétrole et
donc une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie
française mais ceux-ci à trois
conditions d'abord que l'accord de
genève sera respectée ensuite que le
dollar ne s'emballe pas dans les mois
qui viennent y enfin que la hausse des
prix en france reste modérée
actuellement ce sont des objectifs qui
ne paraissent pas hors de portée
la grève des chauffeurs de taxi
aujourd'hui il demande au ministre de
l'intérieur la recherche de mesures
efficaces de protection je rappelle que
l'une de leurs collègues est morte
assassinée il ya quelques jours à saint
quentin pour quelques dizaines de francs
grève également dans les caisses
d'epargne de l'écureuil
aujourd'hui encore à paris en province
entre autres revendications la réduction
du temps de travail à 35 heures sans
perte de salaire
et puis comme chaque année au ministère
de l'agriculture la conférence agricole
avec cet automne une nouveauté l'arrivée
de nouvelles délégations syndicales chez
edith cresson celle du mode s de la rfa
et les travailleurs paysans ce qui ne
fait pas forcément plaisir aux autres
il s'agit encore entre autres dossiers
de parler du revenu agricole
un moment où l'endettement du monde
paysan devient dramatique
un reportage de jean louis calmejane et
de jean vila il y a dix ans daniel
boulogne se lancer dans l'élevage des
cayes
il s'agissait alors d'un petit élevage
familial et artisanale depuis poussé à
produire toujours fui par une demande de
plus en plus importante
son élevage s'est considérablement
agrandi il est aujourd'hui à la tête
d'une véritable petite entreprise qui
emploie 11 personnes
avec comme principal investissement est
un mini abattoirs
et c'est à partir de la construction de
cet abattoir que commencent les
difficultés pour daniel boulogne
difficultés que de nombreux agriculteurs
connaissent comme lui ils ont mis le
doigt dans l'engrenage de
l'investissement obligatoire et du coup
ils sont devenus comme se plaît à le
dire daniel boulogne des esclaves de
l'investissement lors d'un premier temps
3000 kyle semaine 3 4015 semaine pour un
thé l'abattoir n'était pas rentable
abattoirs ne tournait qu'une journée par
semaine
nous avons donc été amené à faire des
nouvelles des nouveaux investissements
au niveau élevage cet élevage
actuellement tourner aux alentours de 14
15 mille caille semaine ce qui fait
tourner l'abattoir trois jours par
semaine
la rentabilité en y nettement améliorée
est-ce que vous avez l'intention encore
de construire d'autres poulailler pour
rentabiliser encore cet abattoir mais
écoutez vu les difficultés rencontrées
sur cet investissement je ne pense pas
pourquoi
si vous voulez l'investissement étant
tellement important toutes les banques
qui ont refusé leur concours
nous avons vu après tellement minime sur
la somme demandée qu encore actuellement
nous sommes être anglais si vous voulez
par les remboursements et cet élevage
n'est pas celui de daniel boulogne
en effet pour rentabiliser encore plus
son abattoir
il a dû faire appel à d'autres éleveurs
mais si un jour il est obligé de mettre
la clé sous la porte comme il le craint
il entraînera avec lui non seulement ses
employés mais aussi tous les éleveurs
concernés
finalement est-ce que vous auriez part
préféré rester à un stade artisanal
si d'une manière si les banques avaient
suivi si vous voulez dans le financement
complet de mon de cet établissement
peut-être bien j'aurais proférées dans
l'élevage de kayes on aurait monté cette
affaire
mais étant donné que ça n'a pas été le
cas je préfère de beaucoup
j'aurais préféré plutôt rester au stade
artisanal aux jambes étaient auparavant
avec un niveau de vie semblable
pratiquement
au-delà de l'histoire exemplaire de
daniel boulogne c'est tout le principe
de l'investissement en agriculture qui
est en question
poussée à investir il ya quelques années
bon nombre d'agriculteurs ont joué le
jeu en augmentant leur productivité
d'abord dans le but d'augmenter leurs
revenus ensuite mais pour beaucoup
d'entre eux au bout du compte le
résultat final a été le contraire du
résultat escompté tchad le gouvenement
on prend les libyens aux mots et leur
demande de se retirer ou souvenez
peut-être qui hier le commandant jalloud
de numéro deux à tripoli avait condamné
toute ingérence étrangère il s'était
engagé à retirer ses troupes dès qu'on
lui demande et bien voilà c'est fait
qu'il est profonde à tripoli c'est
toujours la fête quand un contingent de
l'armée libyenne revient du tchad avoir
une armée qui fait régner l'ordre libyen
à 2000 km de ses frontières
c'était un vieux rêve du colonel kadhafi
mais un rêve qui aujourd'hui s'évanouit
six lances roquettes soviétique c'était
la force de son armée au tchad en huit
ans le corps expéditionnaire libyen
était passé de 200 à dix mille hommes
hier force de paix l'armée de kadhafi
était pratiquement devenu force
d'occupation si le chat demande
aujourd'hui son retrait c'est qu'il se
sent fort de l'appui des autres pays
africains et de la france qui
soutiennent l'envoi d'une force
interafricaine neutre le principe du
retrait des troupes libyennes aient
accepté par les deux parties
s'il ya un principe sur lequel le 4 mai
transigeait pas c'est celui des 100
refus de servir de base à des troupes
étrangères ou de terrain de
déstabilisation contre deux des pays
voisins
en revanche mon pays tient à prince et
l'idée son unité nationale à préserver
de l'apl terrienne et la défense de son
intégrité territoriale
le colonel kadhafi n'a ce soir que deux
solutions entre les mains se retirer du
tchad ou tenter un coup de force mais
qui isolerait un peu plus sur la scène
africaine et internationale
pologne remaniement ministériel général
via ou le ski a obtenu le départ de
trois personnalités très contestée par
solidarité et à l'attrait de son
gouvernement
et puis ensuite toujours pas de solution
à la sphère du sous marin soviétique
échoué depuis trois jours à moins de 15
kilomètres de la base de karlskrona les
habitants de l'archipel genk embarquée
venir est la bête 76 m et milton ils ont
déjà trouvé un surnom tir est la
position inconfortable pour les parfums
whiskey and the rocks souvent s'appelle
whisky je crois que cette actualité
aquatiques nous amène tout droit à la
météo avec alain gillot-pétré et pour
tout le week end et bien il y aura
surtout de la douceur c'est la
principale information douceur
perceptible aujourd'hui oui de la
douceur en effet perceptible aujourd'hui
à 13 heures voici les températures
extrêmes relevé par la météo nationale
à 13h08 degrés c'est le minimum à
grenoble colloque est derrière moi
maximum 19 degrés à ajaccio pour demain
samedi il fera doux donc sur tout le
pays et au sud de la loire en gros
beaucoup de brume et de nuages le matin
puis dans l'après midi
de belles éclaircies se développeront au
nord de la loire toujours temps très
couvert très nuageux avec des pluies
intermittentes surtout le matin du pas
de calais aux rouges mais ça s'arrangera
dans la journée on peut espérer
peut-être pour l'après midi quelques
éclaircies pour dimanche matin dimanche
et bien vous le constatez l'amélioration
sera surtout très sensible au sud de la
loire où il fera très doux après
dissipation des brumes matinales il y
aura de beausoleil au nord de la
bretagne aux vosges et au nord est bien
là le ciel sera nettement plus couvert
avec quelques bruines sur les côtes de
la manche entre ces deux zones du nord
et du sud une zone intermédiaire qui ré
des pays de la loire à la franche comté
est où là et bien là il fera un temps
mitigé avec des éclaircies et des
passages nuageux les températures
prévues pour demain région par région
très douces pour la saison au dessus des
normales de 8 à 10 degrés le matin de 13
à 19
l'après-midi compte tenu des
températures les conseils de lagence
pour les économies d'énergie vous
connaissez la carte là où c'est rouge ou
foncez vous pouvez chauffer sans
problème ailleurs ce n'est pas
nécessaire enfin vous parce que vous
voulez enfin notre effet mairie pour
demain samedi 31 octobre les heures de
lever et du coucher de soleil 7h37 17h31
pour paris et la fête des comptes sains
et je crois qu'on a
d'un petit coin de parapluie pour
georges brassens qu'il aurait simplement
pas aimé qu'on s'apitoie sur sa mort
nous reviendrons sur ces conséquences à
23 heures dans l'émission de jacques
venir lino et puis demain à 12h45 et
philippe labro et puis comme promis nous
allons maintenant entendre de ses
chansons de belles chansons la première
fille puis au bois de mon coeur bonsoir
à tous à demain 21 j'ai tout oublié
qu'en pas à mieux
d'austerlitz et de vathaire l'eau
in italy de bruce et l'espagne 1 de
pontoise et de landerneau
jamais de la vie on le lira la première
fille
qu'on a prise dans ses bras mais la
première rangée
akylone a dit encore t'en souviens-tu
commettent les pêcheurs qu'elles soient
bio net aux filles l'heure rien qu'elle
ne soit plus un qu'elle soit [ __ ]
on se souvient d'elle on s'en souviendra
la première fille à l'abri dans ses bras
moment là
ils sont partis à tire d'aile
mais souvenir de la saison
mais ma mémoire est un fidèle aux
allures heroes et ruiz ont jamais de la
vie
on oublie rend la première fille qu'on a
prise dans ses bras
c'était une bonne affaire en choeur en
souviens que j'ai changé ma vertu contre
une
ils me veulent ce soit en grande pompe
comme les gens bien
dans la zone comme les pauvres et les
chiens
on se souvient des on s'en souvient
d'avoir la première vie qu'on a prise
dans ses bras
toi qui m'as donné
le batteur m pas d'amour
le septième ciel
moins de cadres moi je t'aime eux
dernier cadeau du père noël janvier de
la vie on ne l'oubliera
la première ligne qu'on a prise ans evra
on a beau faire le brave cantet cd&v
tout
dans souviens du on n'en menait pas là
bientôt sans doute le puissant venu où
il devait rendre toutes celles qu'on a
connues pour les lanières que l'on
n'oubliera la première fille prenne à
brisbane et sèmera
non
ouah
clamart il ya les petites fleurs
il ya les petites fleurs ya des corps
peint immoraux bois que mon coeur moreau
bois de mon coeur
au fond de ma course hui renommé
au format court je suis rhône en mer je
suis renommée
avoir le coeur mal famés le meur malfar
mais voir
il ya des petits fleurs y avec douleur
unique a fait corps
au croisement keur au bois de mon coeur
août
quand ya plus de vingt ans montrent non
grâce à plus de 20
jean manteau non
la menthe nous ils n'ont pas la boire
mano de poires moment nous
hu à saint loup ya des petites fleurs ya
les petits fleuves ya l'air
au bois de mon coeur bois le monde
il est ma compagne qu'à la mairie
il m'accompagne
ou à la mairie
la mairie chaque fois que je me marie
que je me marre
ouah
il ya des petites fleurs il ya les
petites flammes
il ya des
open
vos bois de mon coeur oh
auboise mon coeur
chaque fois que je mens fidèlement
chaque fois que je me vide helmand
le monde
il sourire mon enterrement monde en
terre
demande
les quotidiens
le titre
revois ton coeur
au mois d'août